the reason I spend my time on talking
about this is not cuz I want to be a
[ __ ] motivational speaker and
fluffy-fluff fluff and rah rah rah it's
because it's the [ __ ] thing yo yo yo
what up blog busy day today didn't
really film anything on this Friday just
work work work work work work
did filmmaker and askgaryvee how that
goes that's good good asking me everyone
it's awesome anyway nonetheless gave a
talk in Portland a couple weeks ago to
dutch bros coffee company it turned into
an epic i mean an epic do you write how
was it so there's gonna be two and a
half hour episode daily not yeah it's
when an hour episode of daily be touched
on a ton of new content i think you guys
are going to super enjoy it and sit back
pour a glass of wine from the gary vee
wine club oh wait what you're not part
of the gary vee wine club you're up are
you part of the family you know seven
are you part of the kick yeah guys don't
be a [ __ ]
sign up for the gary vee my club and
watch the snap let's welcome to the
stage rooster Gary Vaynerchuk
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's go let's go sit down
let's do this what up what up what up
what up uh thank you for having me thank
you so much for the awesome intro and
reaction very frankly how are we doing
the QA where's the q- come from you guys
have runners awesome cool I'm just super
I just can't wait to get to the Q & A so
I just wanted to get that out there and
the reason I wanted to the QA to be very
frank is I think I get to speak a lot
and when I think about speaking at the
end of the day I'm trying to reverse
engineer the audience right to me as a
lot of you know how many people here
have seen some of my content online
raise your hands
thank you actually real quick how many
you have you have not raised your hands
okay [ __ ] you guys kidding kidding okay
so for about 70% of you you guys have
seen the content and I'll go through
certain things that I want to talk to
you guys about for the 30 or 40% of you
that just raise your hands that you
haven't you can go to YouTube or
Facebook and see this and so what's
super important to me is to make this
talk contextual and when I think about
this audience and and whether it's of
age or mindset the youth and the offense
of this organization is super attractive
to me it from afar right for me I'm 41
I'm old but I feel 16 in my mind right
and I and I work like I'm 19 you know in
my prime because I'm on the offense it's
a mindset and so the thing that I want
to first start with is intangibles right
I've been thinking about this quite a
bit and let me tell you why this is the
first thing I want to start with
yesterday for some of you that know I'm
a ridiculously diehard Jets fan right
and yesterday the Jets [ __ ] me up
because they won a football game so for
some of you that aren't into football my
strategy for this season was to go Oh in
16 and take a quarterback with the first
pick and so I literally was in the
stands yesterday in New York really
upset as my team was da man
and archrival in the Miami Dolphins and
all the fans around me were pissed
because I was like booing when the Jets
were doing good [ __ ] in the hole
it was [ __ ] awkward okay but here's
what happened
the Jets took a player this year by the
name of Jamal Adams out of LSU and he
basically was disproportionally
impactful on the game yesterday without
doing anything that you would normally
consider a turning point
he didn't have an interception for a
touchdown he didn't do any of the things
that would show up in the stat sheets
that would make you say oh he won the
game as the defensive back
what he did was intangibles what he did
was the hour before the game the way he
interacted with all his teammates didn't
look anything like a kid playing his
third game of his life and pros it
looked like a 16-year veteran doing the
little things what he did was on every
play when the Dolphins made a mistake or
an offsides he basically looked at the
entire crowd which was half-empty and
would get them excited what he did was
when a teammate came off the field that
made a nice play on special teams he ran
over and gave him gaps
he literally fundamentally willed the
vibe of the game to go in a direction
that created the outcome I am not
physically structured to win all my
competitive battles through my life yet
when I think about all the one-on-one
basketball games or the floor hockey
matches or the ping-pong matches or
tennis or football or whatever like 80%
of the time when I [ __ ] win something
in a physical confrontation sporting
event it's because I used intangibles to
out mentally maneuver or
disproportionally figure out how to win
I am fascinated fascinated by this I am
fascinated by [ __ ] mindset I am
fascinated in a complicated world that
we're all growing up in it's a binary
decision if you're gonna be positive or
negative about [ __ ]
I'm fascinated that when you're addicted
to kindness and optimism and positivity
it just you know it's so funny you know
you know like stuff like this secret
like I love when people talk about like
the secret like that black people think
you sit on your ass on your couch and
you're like
I had a million bucks and it's like
bloop and it just shows up what I'm
fascinated by is the reason people
succeed that put their mindset into it
is because it does something that has
really also caught my attention over the
last two years which is the following
when you bet on optimism when you're on
the offense when you were playing
towards intangibles you do something
SuperDuper interesting you start
suffocating excuses if you asked me what
the number-one thing is that I'm
thankful for that my parents gave me
taking me from a communist country
moving me to the US you know parenting
me well nothing bad you know roof and
clothes and all good stuff if you ask me
the number one thing I wake up every
morning and thank that my parents did is
I never saw either one of them complain
about Jack yet and it basically created
learned behavior for me I'm incapable of
actually complaining about yet and that
has become the foundation of my success
when I was in my toy you know when I was
in my 20s and early 30s I spent eight 15
16 17 hours a day for 13 years building
my dad's liquor store for him I own
nothing of Wine Library right I you know
I leave that business in my mid-30s I
have no wealth
I built a 60 million dollar wine
business for my dad and I don't sit
there and complain I think about it as I
did the right thing by thanking my
parents and giving back to literally
literally no joke if I leave this
conference today right now if I leave
right we do this we have a nice little
Q&A it's a good talk it's [ __ ] cool I
leave I go to cross the street to go
into my car to go to the airport and I
get hit by a car literally as I'm laying
there I'm like [ __ ] I shouldn't have
left the conference that early like it
is in my mindset that literally every
negative thing that happens to me is my
[ __ ] fault
I recognize that that's not true you
know when I talk about this publicly
everybody starts bringing up stuff like
like what if you're raped and what of
this and that I understand I'm a logical
practical person I'm not talking about
knowing or thinking everything is my
fault I'm talking about living a life
where you default into believing that as
your mindset because what happened
is you start spending all of your time
on offense
my friends do you guys like listen
here's what [ __ ] freaks me the [ __ ]
out
do you understand you like that let me
let me get to it it's really interesting
to me I wish everybody in this
conference including myself by the way
who spends all his time on this I wish
we had better perspective I wish that
there was some [ __ ] crazy that dude
right there with the weird [ __ ] horse
t-shirt I wish he was some weird genie
that could take us back into time eighty
years ago so that every one of you could
live one [ __ ] day in your
great-great-grandparents shoes and
understand how [ __ ] good you have it
like if you really really understood how
amazing the year we live in and listen
I'm not I'm not like naive to what's
happening in our society I'm aware of
the political current climate I'm aware
of everything let me just say this very
clear so everybody gets it through their
[ __ ] dome this is the greatest year
to ever be alive in the history of
mankind I am I am super empathetic again
when you make those kind of statements
do I believe that there is suppression
around the force but at a macro data
macro data health life expectancy how
much hate and negativity actually is in
the complete world verse this is the
best we have it the best and all I see
is people sitting around and dwelling
around dumb [ __ ] around what they don't
have instead of focusing on what they do
have my friends the Internet is a
[ __ ] miracle it's a [ __ ] miracle
the scalability in which you can achieve
the things that you could be doing the
fact that you could be laying [ __ ]
naked in your bed at 2:00 in the morning
and doing productive [ __ ] is [ __ ]
crazy it's crazy when oh if you've got
your side hustle it's young [ __ ] ass
crap if you think about your side hustle
or if you're crushing it with these guys
and doing side hustle there was no side
hustle for your great-grandparents like
like when it was 9:00 p.m. it was dark
and cold out
sigh like [ __ ] was like you could it
wasn't practical we take things for
granted do you know upset you know how
like you know what's crazy to me how mad
I get when my internet is a hundredth of
a second slower than what I'm used to
like like literally like it a hundredth
of a second slower and I feel it because
I'm used to what speed it's supposed to
be and that's frustrating like on a
plane because the Wi-Fi on a plane is a
little slow which is like so ridiculous
because I'm on a [ __ ] plane and then
it's Wi-Fi it's there like I'm old I
remember not having it like it's crazy
how quickly we take things for granted
like I love be my buddy so London just
banned uber and like my buddy landed
there and he's like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do I'm like I don't know what
everybody's done for last 300 years dick
face take the trip like we just get used
to [ __ ] so fast and in our speed of
getting used to how [ __ ] awesome it
is I'm just desperate this afternoon for
you to not lose perspective perspectives
the [ __ ] game right both my
grandfather I sit up here get paid
super-duper-duper well get people to
think I'm cool because I have
entrepreneurial DNA and the timing of it
was cool because entrepreneurs got cool
both my grandfather's had the same exact
thing that I had and because they were
Jewish in communist Russia post-world
War two their communism put them both in
jail for 10 years in Siberia like just
think about that timing opportunity yes
it is absolutely difficult for all of us
we all have stuff do I believe some
people have it do I believe a white male
has a mortal yes I do here's my problem
my problem is if anybody has ever done
it with your circumstances then you have
nothing to talk about in the mindset
that I want for you to win if anybody
has ever achieved something with two
alcoholic parents that's the blueprint
that you can follow versus looking the
other way life is binary
it's either offense or deep
faites you are there sitting in your
seat right now on the offense or you're
not there is no [ __ ] half pregnant
there's no in-between
you're either this or that and so I come
here with the energy to let you know
about how I see it from afar not knowing
every nuance of your life hey I think
this is the greatest opportunity to be
alive
because the Internet has created
infinite opportunity for all of us B I
love something that I'm fascinated by
which is that everything gets
accelerated what you're living through
right now my friends in society and the
business world is everything's getting
accelerated what the Internet has done
it hasn't changed us it's exposed us
what the Internet has done is not
necessarily suppress things it's made
everything at the forefront there's no
hiding everything is so clear out and he
opened difficult to hide and so I'm
fascinated by this because it leads to
bigger opportunity to speed in which
good can happen is extraordinary it just
comes down to actions so what's really
happening this first and foremost this
device if you're sitting in your seat
and you have any entrepreneurial
intrapreneurial DNA aka
do you want to be the CEO of this
company one day and grow in the ranks or
do you want to do something for yourself
one day if you have either one which I
assume is one or the other inside your
body you have to take a step back and
wrap your head around the following this
right here
this device is the remote control of our
society this is everything everybody
keeps trying to tell people to spend
less time on this I recommend you spend
all your time on it I don't give a [ __ ]
if you look at another human beings eyes
again this this because where do you
think the world's going I love you know
I have two young kids now and I love all
these parents like Gary you're into this
social media stuffing is terrible right
I'm like no dick this is the best
because I'm like they're like but I'm
gonna tell my kid to spend less time on
technology I'm like why what world do
you think your kids are gonna be living
in in 20 years you think like I love the
naivete the naivete this is all history
my friends people thinking we're gonna
go backwards every person this
is gonna be wearing contact lenses
full-time on their body in 20 years and
triggering between real-life authentic
reality where like I don't know Santa's
on here in stage with me right and
complete virtual reality everybody in
here and 20 to 25 years is going to be
living a mixed reality world you may not
like it you may think it's weird but
people used to think online dating was
weird people used to think the internet
was weird people definitely thought
sending a 14 year old girl into a
stranger's car
was super weird and that's what we do
with all our daughters now at 14 and put
them into humors and strange men's cars
every day social norms are changing at a
speed that we've never seen before so
this amplification of everything is what
I want to focus on right now I wrote a
book six years ago called the Thank You
economy and I want to talk to you guys
about it today because I think it
matters for most of you right now
it is stunning to me how doing a good
deed now travels to such a greater
length than it ever did before to me if
you took anything away from my talk
before I go into the Q&A I want you to
understand the following somebody is
always watching now there is no
interaction that you're having ever
again that is just between you and that
person and let me tell you why I want
you to think this way though that may be
true right because it becomes he-said
she-said though that may be true if you
switch and live the mindset that I've
been living for the last seven years I
really believe that a lot of good things
will happen for you if you believe that
every single thing that you do is on the
record you will be stunned by how your
behavior changes if you actually believe
that every single thing you do is
actually being documented is actually
going to be recorded is actually being
watched a miraculous thing happens you
change your behavior not that you go
from being a dick to being phenomenal
it's just and I'm telling you because
I've been living in for the last decade
you just start sliding every so often a
little bit towards a better place and it
starts changing your behavior and what
happens is you start having moment
some of positivity I believe that karma
is practical I believe that doing the
right thing is always the right thing
and so how many people here are managers
raise your hands
some fat actually can you guys stand up
if your manager just stand up real quick
don't get lazy on me let's get the blood
going
let's not clap up for them they don't
need to be clapped I'm trying to get
fine clap clap alright you could sit can
we keep the lights on it's better I like
seeing their faces I'm fascinated by
management how many people became a
manager in the last within the last two
years raise your hand
funny [ __ ] right used to be fun saying
your manager was a [ __ ] until you
became one now you're like oh now I get
it
management's super interesting to me I'm
super fasting by I have 800 employees of
vaynermedia and I love watching somebody
go from superstar entry or sext here and
when they go to management [ __ ] changes
because everything flips what managers
don't let me let me tell you something
managers I run vaynermedia on the CEO
800 employees I work for everybody I
don't have people working for me I work
for everybody the biggest issue that
managers have when they make that leap
is they get very [ __ ] confused they
think that people work for them and they
all understand that they're working for
those people and so when I think about
the Thank You economy and being
documented and what I really want from
you I'm not here to razz the managers I
want everybody who just stood up to get
to the place that they want to in their
lives and their careers and I want to
suffocate real quick for all of them to
leave their [ __ ] fancy POVs at the
[ __ ] door because what happens as you
grow up the ranks of society in life and
in business is you have to start
deploying humility not ego and that has
been the most fascinating thing that
I've watched through my career watching
that shift become difficult for it
because the way to succeed within an
organization that has people working is
you have to figure out how to learn to
eat [ __ ] and that is super difficult and
the higher up you go the more [ __ ] you
have to eat the amount of [ __ ] that I
eat every day is so [ __ ] staggering
to me and it is basically the blueprint
of my success and every other person
that I've seen literally your ability to
be the bigger man and woman in every
situation even though 9 out of 10 times
you may be right is the variable of your
success both within an organization and
compounded when you go out into the real
world and this takes me back to where I
started please understand the following
being nice is ROI positive it is
travelling it is being known it is
leveraged the ability to be not nice
politicking on the defense always wins
upfront which is why people are seduced
by it but it never wins the long game
your winning the sprint for about 40
seconds but you never win the marathon
of what's being played here it is now
compounded because information about us
travels at a level we've never seen
before being a dick in Portland in 1974
was super fine because you could move to
Minnesota that information now travels
with us at scale you don't even want to
know how much of a jerk your
great-great-grandfather was all that
stuff is lost in history all of our
baggage here forever the biggest thing I
remind people when they go on tilt
whether it's politics or life or
whatever is just remember everything
you're saying is going to be there
forever everybody in this room is going
to have a conversation with their
granddaughter and they're gonna have to
explain their points of view on
everything - now forget politics life
everything and so I'm fascinated by this
dynamic I think it's a super interesting
time and I really want to not in spite
you know it's really funny I think about
like what like I don't really get a
super high to inspire or make like a fun
event I get a super high on the emails I
read on the way out to this flight this
morning the people that were in
audience the guy who just told me
backstage that when he saw me to speak
two years ago quit his job one of the
offense I'm in it for one thing legacy
I'm in it for one person sitting here
emailing me in six years and saying you
know I was a little fancy as a manager
until you came to Portland I was a
little high on myself and thinking I was
special I was building towards the wrong
path that wasn't gonna be historically
correct and I am just fascinated by the
fact that the most simple of traits now
is the fundamental game we're playing
that it's crazy to me as we go more
Jetsons the people that know how to play
like The Flintstones are gonna win
literally I believe the manners that
your great-great-grandparents have are
far more suited for where we're going
than the majority of us that we don't
realize what's actually happening in
front of us which is we are all not just
be all they putting out content
d-roc where you at you know not just
[ __ ] having a weird dude following
you around full time filming you not me
all of you may be mine's an extreme
version but for all of you all of you
you were documenting your entire life at
scale forever
and when you start wrapping your head
around that two things unfold I hope for
95% of you number one the quality of the
life that you're trying to live as a
human so that you're proud about the
conversations you have at 60 70 and 80
and when you get there a funny thing
happens as you push yourself to be a
better [ __ ] human being better things
start happening for you in your actual
selfish business wants and needs and so
I hope that I can suffocate and ignite a
mindset here today of people actually
understanding what they're doing think
about all the dumb [ __ ] you believed
five years ago that you don't believe
anymore
we keep evolving we keep changing as we
grow
I implore you to understand how big the
stakes are in the world that you live in
right now the opportunity is so
ridiculous and so let's get into the
details before I get into Q&A of this
I am desperate for every person in this
room to understand a couple pieces of
data number one if you believe that this
is the remote control of our society the
way I do then it gets really interesting
when you start thinking about social
media social media is this nice little
in my marketing world it's a slang term
for a nice to have that you support with
television things that nature obviously
with a lot of young faces its norm for
you it's the main communication funnel
but it probably has a balance between
business and your real life and what
you're doing as a human I need everybody
understand something more than 50% of
the time spent by all Americans on a
cell phone is on a social network this
is pretty much the punchline like by the
time how many people here are retiring
in ten years and I don't mean you're
gonna open up a bunch of these and
you're gonna [ __ ] crush it buy an
island I mean you're [ __ ] old and
you're finished how many people retiring
in the next ten years great zero so for
everybody here please understand the
following everything everything that is
running our society's attention right
out Facebook and YouTube and Instagram
and snapchat and Twitter and everything
twelve years ago did not exist the
smartphone did not exist
uber did not exist Airbnb did not exist
nothing like if everybody really you
know back to the awesome dude with the
[ __ ] horse t-shirt the reason I wish
she could take everybody back is we do
not have context to how remarkable like
it's tough the people that lived during
the Great Depression the people that
live during the world wars the people
that live during the industrial
revolution
it's hard because it's our lives it's
hard for us to understand how different
it is for us than the prior two
generations it's difficult because you
have no context to anything else but the
stakes and opportunity are all time
they're all time our great grandkids
everybody else will look back at this
era as the moment and so I implore you
to take a step back and really
fundamentally ask yourselves a couple
questions one what legacy are you
building because it will be the leverage
for everything that you want over the
next 60 years and that is
based on your actions and to very
honestly are you squeezing the [ __ ] out
of this moment as much as you can
the thing that I'm super passionate
about is a lot of you know is I think
work ethic is the one thing that's super
[ __ ] controllable right like a lot of
us were born with what we were born less
right like you're only so pretty
you're only so smart you're only so fast
you know like you're only what you are
the one thing that I am fascinated by as
you sit here the way you were parented
where you were born what you got the one
thing that actually is in your control
is the decisions of what you do with
your hand it's like a great poker player
right a great poker player doesn't need
the best hand every time to win it's how
she or he navigates with that hand we're
not gonna change who we are or where we
were born or to whom we were born with
but no matter where you are in a life
cycle right now we all have the
opportunity to start looking at a little
different and to me very frankly I just
think we spent an enormous amount of
time on dumb [ __ ] when we have ambition
to do so much more now look you do you
I'm no and I'm not interested in
peddling being a workaholic I'm really
not you can do whatever you want the
happiest friend I know from growing up I
think it makes $50,000 a year he's on 17
[ __ ] softball teams he [ __ ] takes
every vacation day off and he's happiest
[ __ ] and I I love him and it makes me so
damn happy I friends who were early
employees at Facebook they have a
hundred million dollars in a bank and
they're miserable and it's [ __ ] this is
not a money conversation this is very
simply your actions back up your mouth
to me looking at the hash tag looking at
people talking about this looking at
their social media I got you know when I
have the whole East Coast to West Coast
long flight I get into a lot of work I
get all my work done and then I start
looking at all of your social media on
the way here and I look at the hashtag
and I see what you said about the
earlier speaker and I do my thing right
the thing that fascinated me a lot about
this conference is you've got a lot of
people peacocking in this organization
there's a look aka a lot of you were
talking
[ __ ] and I don't mean about this
conference I went back and looked at all
your tweets did you know there were 37
billionaires sitting with us today I'm
fascinated by that
I'm fascinated because we're sitting in
a world right now where entrepreneurship
is on a pedestal of cool
so everybody's flocked to it and
everybody's talking about how they're
gonna crush it and what they're gonna do
and who they're gonna be and then you
look at their content and every Friday
night they're at a [ __ ] concert and
every Sunday morning they're this and
every Tuesday afternoon they're that and
they watch a shitload of [ __ ] Netflix
and they're incredible at [ __ ] candy
crush and [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and so
I go on this rant not to do anything or
to razz or to [ __ ] call anybody out
I'm just asking a very simple question I
promise you if you wanna be pumped
professionally and personally there's
one thing that will drive you to the
biggest success it's called
self-awareness do you know who you are
do you know what you're about are you
actually talking about [ __ ] that you
care about are you talking because three
or four people that you love talk that
game and you just feel like you've got
to fit in or appease your mom or dad or
uncle or aunt or grandmother's ambition
the thing that helped me so much was
just self-awareness in fourth grade I
punted school cuz I knew I sucked at it
I knew that I could make $3,000 a
weekend as a ten-year-old selling
baseball cards but I couldn't spell 90%
of the words or being thrown at me it
was just who I was it was how I was
wired and I implore everybody in this
conference to really think about this
incredibly interesting thing which is
when you're self-aware and you can get
to that place of understanding yourself
I implore you to triple down on your
strengths and Punk your weaknesses this
country is really good at selling down
our throats what we're not good at we're
always being sold what to fix I truly
believe that most of the people in this
room will succeed by not addressing
those things now something could be
fatal right like something could really
hurt you but I think you need to just
lift those get them to a certain place
so they're not a vulnerability and
triple down on your charisma and triple
down on your salesmanship and triple
down on your work ethic whatever those 3
to 4 1 2 3 4 5 pillars are it's
fascinating when you study who's winning
and who's not it's the people that have
the confidence to suck at [ __ ] that are
winning I can't read right like I'm
terrible at it like reading them too you
know
a second grade book - my daughter's like
a bird you know like like yet standing
in front of 800,000 people like cool I'm
good like we need to start thinking more
and more and as you're going through
your careers right now I implore you to
be confident what you're good at and to
punt what you suck out cuz I promise you
everybody else sucks at [ __ ] -
everybody's got strengths and weaknesses
and I'm fascinated by people's obsession
to pour all their efforts into fixing
their weaknesses which is playing
defense and not triple letting down on
strengths so if I leave you with
anything structurally from a strategy
standpoint and mindset standpoint I
highly implore you on that and that's it
like don't those are the things that are
really kind of happening to me
I'm fascinated that we're in this era I
want people to take bigger advantages of
it right I need people to understand how
ridiculously unbelievable it is and to
figure out do they really want stuff do
they lovely how many people love working
because they just love the game of
trying to win at a career or building a
business raise your hands those people
are gonna have a disproportionate
Vantage because it doesn't feel like
work it's just their zone for the rest
of you you need to figure out what you
like about it and spend all your time on
that because if you're in a place where
you don't like it you're not gonna put
in the amount of work that's needed to
actually achieve the things that most of
you want it's very very simple put
yourself in a position to succeed put
yourself in a position to succeed and I
will file how many people here feel like
they are
not self-aware because I want to address
this if I can just raise your hands if
you struggle you think a little bit with
self-awareness raise your hands nobody
want some reference I'll just go to it
cuz III respect why that's a tough one
why we got half the hands that we should
have and more importantly the ones I got
we're [ __ ] you know crocodile hands if
you're listening for the last seven
minutes and I'm going through towards
unfun ter I'm going through an awkward
territory I'm going there because it has
been clearly in the last four years the
thing that I've seen that has won and
lost I would highly implore you take the
five people that spend the most time
with you co-workers or family members if
you feel like you're struggling with
this issue and invite them to dinner
create a weird event where it's like
your mom and a co-worker know what the
[ __ ] is happening create a weird event
and tell everybody like you really want
to figure out what you're good at when
you're not good at and spend three hours
getting the people that love you or know
you the best comfortable with telling
you the truth because nobody wants to
tell you because most people are kind
right we don't tell people because we
like each other like especially the
people that are closest to you but this
is something I throw out about a year
ago in a blog post maybe two years ago
and it's been the thing that I've been
most emailed about it's remarkable and
it's an unlock because when you don't
see it when you're blinded to it you're
doing the same repeat behavior that's
stopping you from the thing and once you
can break it if you have the humility to
be comfortable with yourself to go there
it's a humongous unlock and it is the
disproportion reason listen my friends a
lot of people when they talk about
technology and social media and
investing in business they want me to
talk about details right like we're
about to do Q&A like we'll go to it now
because it's run in two minutes I
promise and if you want to ask me a
simple question of how to get more
Instagram followers I'm thrilled to
answer to you I'm thrilled I will give
you everything I've got in detail but if
you ask me why I get to sit here today
if you ask me why I believe he's been
able to build this business my friends
all the magic is in the gray it's not in
the black and white all the tactics you
can Google right now you can google
anything you want you want to do
Facebook ads better it's the best deal
in marketing you want to sell [ __ ] do
Facebook advertising your company should
do a shitload more Facebook advertising
I should do
we're Facebook advertising it's a [ __ ]
steel it's the steel right Instagram
influencers [ __ ] steel people don't
know how to price themselves to give you
awareness some are overpriced some are
underpriced [ __ ] steel under 30
snapchat ads $3 CPM swipe up people are
watching videos these are the details
but if you're [ __ ] insecure it's not
gonna mean dick if you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing with yourself it's
not gonna mean [ __ ] the reason I spend
my time on talking about this is not cuz
I want to be a [ __ ] motivational
speaker and fluffy-fluff fluff and rah
rah rah it's because it's the [ __ ]
thing it's the thing if your operating
system isn't right you got no [ __ ]
chance if you're not [ __ ] it up do
you know how [ __ ] unbeatable I feel
do you know that if you think I'm the
best that I'm [ __ ] the best and
you're wearing my [ __ ] hoodie and I'm
the [ __ ] best do you know how good
that feels phenomenal do you know if
you're sitting here right now never
heard of me like [ __ ] this guy I don't
like his bravado I don't give a [ __ ]
either I don't care if you think I'm the
best I don't care if you think I'm the
worst I'm just in my [ __ ] cuz I'm
grounded because I know what I am and I
know how I'm trying to live my life and
I want that for every [ __ ] person
because let me tell you something if
[ __ ] is the best it's such a good
place to be
do you know what it's like to be in your
own head and nothing else matters do you
know what it feels like to give a [ __ ]
so much about what everybody thinks
yet not care at all do you know that
when I leave here I'm gonna look at
every single tweet about this talk and
if somebody said yeah I'm gonna be
devastated like I [ __ ] died yet
equally don't give a [ __ ] when you can
get to that place amazing [ __ ] happens
you know why cuz you stop being scared
when you're not scared you do [ __ ] when
you're scared you do nothing and when
you're not scared you do [ __ ] and even
better when you're coming from a good
place and you're intense good because
you're good and you have good to give
[ __ ] really starts happening and so I
implore you let's go get the mics ready
I'm ready let's go into the QA but I
implore you I'll go into every detail
but I implore you to get inside your
head real quick figure out who you
really are and figure out if what you're
talking
being mapped by what you're doing
because the second you put those things
together [ __ ] [ __ ] unlocks thank you
[Applause]
let's do it let's go to the good part
all right how we doing this just line up
in the rows line up behind you and line
up here great what's your name hello
[Applause]
thank you thank you okay so I watch tons
and tons of your content your videos for
daily beast I listen your podcast a
question that I was thinking about for a
while is how do you as a leader motivate
your team to be just as hungry and
passionate as you are and make them
wanna bust ass just as hard I don't I
think it's crazy for CEOs and owners of
things to expect their staff to bust
their ass and be as hungry as them
because when you own something it's
different and so what I do is I try to
motivate by meeting each and every one
of them the reason you've seen it that I
meet with all of them and do those
meetings is I don't need them I want to
buy the New York Jets
I need like seven billion [ __ ]
dollars I work 18 hours a day I wake up
at 4:30 to be here today I'm going back
on the red-eye this was original I was
supposed to sleep here nope neither I
need to get three meetings in tomorrow
I'm taking a [ __ ] [ __ ] red-eye
tonight like I don't expect that from
others because most people aren't insane
to like have this romantic point-of-view
of like not being able to buy a jet
jersey for 20 bucks when he first came
to America to owning the team I've got a
[ __ ] you on me got it I don't expect
that for anybody else what I want to
know is what makes every one of them
tick do you know many people just want
to make 200 thousand a year and have
great work-life balance that's [ __ ]
unbelievable that's [ __ ] hitting the
lot like if you are the kind of person
that is obsessed with making $200,000 a
year and be able to go to all the
sporting events of your wonderful
children that's incredible balance and
if that's what you want I want to
empower you to do that I think the
biggest mistake that leaders make is
they expect others to care about their
[ __ ] as much as they do that's [ __ ]
ludicrous I want to figure out what you
care about and it's my job to put you in
a position to succeed to be hungry and
if that means seeing every [ __ ]
recital of your little Susie I'm gonna
[ __ ] do that for you
what up G how I bruh franchise oh is
this the thing we do right like you say
where you're from and your four people
in a gear what up [ __ ] what sir god I
got it just trying to get it down trying
to get it down I got it now I got it I'm
from vaynermedia New York d-roc give me
some yeah all right go ahead everybody
here has passion clearly and we give so
much and I mean it could be passion with
our job it could be passion without side
whatever you guys are so ridiculously
lucky I've rarely met Anna MAHT we have
an internal job board and five full-time
employees I try to help people get jobs
to leave our company because we want it
better for them I've literally never
sensed a truer purity of that mission as
much as you guys have as well and it's
remarkable you guys are very fortunate
and it stems from the top and and
like-minded people find each other it's
really rad I'm really impressed I'm
super pumped to be here good like do you
ever hold back any of your passion like
does it ever maybe get the best of you
sometimes and you have to maybe take a
couple steps back of your legs like I
may have gone too far
why would you like so the answer's no
but what's but but more importantly the
question so for me it's kind of like I
do lots of things that have passion that
I'm not pumped about for example let's
go back to football two years ago at a
Jets Steelers game there was like at 80
right very good
Jets are getting Jets are beating the
Steelers four note this four years ago
for no reason Steelers were much better
Jets were bad that year Jets are on the
verge of winning this 85 year old guy is
coming up the stairs and I get sports
muscles when I'm in Jets world I'm not
me it's the only place I'm not me I get
too emotional right so the guys walking
up and the Jets are winning into the
fourth quarter and I stand up cuz I'm
ridiculous and I'm like hey old man
you're finished old man you're fit
right and everybody's kind of looking at
me because I'm super inappropriate and
then I go and I don't mean the game
right so my passion went too far there
so I understand unless the odds that I
understand I get it
what I guess ultimately what I'm trying
first of all I think I just wanted to
tell you that story because it's so
[ __ ] up I needed to get it out of me
it's so horrible I'm glad I was able to
share I feel better now it makes people
creeped out bro honestly as long as
you're coming from a good place so I do
the same thing I curse I've got tons of
but I'm coming from such a good place
that I'm not trying to impose any
negativity as long as your passions
coming from a good place and it's not a
stick because you think it's helping you
and it's an act and it's not trying to
do something that's bad for them you're
[ __ ] good let the chips fall your Sam
you got it this is back to self
awareness you've got to ask yourself two
very important questions number one is
it a stick are you doing it because it's
self interest and it's a narrative
you're trying to pay to do something
selfish for you number two are you doing
it to suppress somebody because you're
insecure about their skills that you
don't have as long as it's neither one
of those to [ __ ] be as passionate as
you want welcome
Wow yes hi Gary hi I'm Erica nice to
meet you nice to meet you Erica
I run the social media pages for the
Spokane Dutch bro Spokane yeah months
ago I was at an agency running their
social media department I was miserable
not my kind of humans just not my place
I watched her videos for about a year
telling me the hustle telling me to do
it just work harder so I quit my job I
started my own social media company and
I feel blessed but in three months I've
doubled my salary and it's really taken
off a lot to do with these people but so
my next question for you is how do I go
to the next step you know I've got the
small business hustling or yep twelve
hours a day
yep how do I get to 800 staff it's not
what you want I want yeah I picture my
company's called talk fast social yep I
picture a TFS on a building every day
and I work for it love it
so how old are you 26 good all right
step number one the next ten years of
your life you have to close your eyes
and think about nothing else now that
doesn't mean you can't find love it
doesn't mean you can't do other things
but the only way you can build something
very very very big is you put those on a
building and you put in the back of your
mind and you close your eyes
the biggest reason almost everybody
fails in their big ambitions is cuz of
lack of patience you know I talk about
this all the time people struggle
because they want what they do is they
get a little success and then they start
getting greedy in a good way not like
I'm using it as a slang term for like
okay right you got a little momentum
you're like wait a minute
[ __ ] I can do this and then you people
start getting greedy and they overextend
themselves because they're rushing so
fast to do like people like literally
say things to me like I gotta do five
million or I gotta put my name on a
building they make up these things like
the Jets thing the just thing is not
even real for me I've talked about it a
little bit I guess really want to buy
the Jets because I think I'm more likely
to win a Super Bowl for them than any
other way right but but the chase of
trying to buy them is what gets me off
not getting it I've forever in my life
have never needed anything not a certain
dollar amount not some vision of the
building and I'm not saying that's what
you you know what I mean
I'm just telling you it's one step in
front of the other
patients and doing tried-and-true things
I leave money on the table at extreme
levels every year because I'm being
patient and building real legacy and
real relationship step by step by step
by step you just got to close your
[ __ ] eyes for the next decade you're
welcome hey how are you I'm great are
you great Chico there's like six of us
she come so I did like yawn he's like
all right good so you have a chief
officer yes yes um so when you bring her
on yes uh what's that discussion like
when you talk about her objectives do
you have like kpi's things that are
memorable are there incentives like how
much detail can you go into our puns
telling me how much she makes stuff like
that but whatever how much can you tell
me about how to make it something that's
as objective as possible for someone
like that to be successful so it's so
cheap so first of all it's a great
question and asking about the black and
white around it it's super interesting
to me because it is the most gray role
in our organization right so for example
lifetime retention of employees is not a
KPI because if we think Karen I mean if
we meet like the young one we just met
we may encourage her to start her own
company like I'm trying to push six or
seven of my best people out and be like
you need to start your own company
because we're gonna have a problem in
three years because you're such an a and
like you just need to like to scratch
this itch so I'll be very honest with
you i micromanage HR for twenty years
that I ran my companies in my entire
life
it wasn't until I found a soul mate in
Clawd who literally looked at all
situations the same and she was on the
account side and then she left Vayner
and I cornered her to come back to do a
totally different role because the truth
is the KPI is how do you keep 800 people
1500 people
four thousand people happy with the
machine and by the way it's impossible
the level of cynicism that is in our
society is extraordinary it's so hard to
prove to somebody that you care
everybody is so scared to trust because
they don't want to get hurt
that it's easier to be cynical I
understand but all the Claude and I do I
mean the whole flight here we text about
individual people I know exactly what's
going on right now with Christians Walde
right and in exactly what's going to
happen with Joe Cutrone and why we move
Natalie Carrie to a different pod right
like I'm so [ __ ] in it but there you
know we have lightweight kpi's but
Claude and I are outside the lines you
know drawers we surround ourselves with
people making sure all the things that
are black and white that people are
getting I mean like simple things like
people getting raises appropriately at
the time they're promised like not like
not me but just silly [ __ ] that you know
we've got the special part down we
surround ourselves to make sure we don't
drop the ball in the commodity the key
is how the [ __ ] do we get everybody to
feel good every day right that they know
that we've got their back whether they
work with us for one more day like every
time somebody quits in a weird way I
always grab them always I'm like dude
what the [ __ ] man I put out content
every day I've told you I've emailed you
like why wouldn't you use me if you were
so unhappy I could have gotten you a job
for 50 like if you felt like like the
other day like well I felt I was
underpaid I'm like dude you got $11,000
pay bump hey I would have been thrilled
to give it to you but way more
importantly there's like 11 people that
need people like you that I'm friends
with right now and you could got a 45
let me help you we basically what I'm
trying to do is build real trust through
scaling the unscalable one-on-one
conversations the problem is that we're
learning is at first it worked
unbelievably but now she becomes too
much of the machine so she's me it's me
and her right now we're like the parents
or the siblings so you got to bring in
other things I used to have an open-door
policy not working 2018 mandated 15
minutes with every [ __ ] employee I
have twice a year mandated it's gonna
take me enormous amounts of time I don't
care it's all I've got religion you know
I don't care what the church or the
synagogue or the temple or the mosque is
decorated like I care about the religion
and too many people care about you know
she makes hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars
nobody's bonused at vaynermedia because
I want everybody to be obsessed with the
logo and so when people talk to me about
their incentive packages or things that
they charge just match and put it into
their salary and the way we some people
go will then Rd incentivize no they're
not if you don't [ __ ] achieve we fired
[ __ ] face cool hey what's up Gary how
are you good how are you amazing
my name is Nick I'm with these lovely
people from Redding California right
here all right so I took over managing
and my stand
earlier this year okay and one of the
more interesting things like the
challenges I've come across is
identifying qualities and people that I
think would translate well into them
moving into leadership and management so
I was curious for you if you have
someone in your companies here looking
at to put in leadership or management
what are some of the most important
qualities that you look for empathy
empathy is [ __ ] disproportionately
important for leaders if you are not
capable of thinking about the other
person first you are finished
empathy work ethic I think work ethic
matters you know it's tough right
because if you're not working as hard as
your team or harder that starts becoming
a vulnerability gratitude is one that I
look for quite a bit are they actually
grateful or they entitled and think of
course I'm gonna be a management like I
look for crap but empathy is like
[ __ ] eighty percent of it and then
the other 20% is work ethic gratitude
things like that yeah you got it
what's up dude hey bro I'm Mitch and I
guess I'm here with everybody because I
think we're all here for the same reason
respect
yeah um also this adrenaline rush is
like the best adrenaline rush I've
gotten since like high school so they
create it
thank you real quick yeah paint me the
picture of what was happening in high
school when you felt this honestly I'd
say it was like my last respect that's
not what we thought yeah all right keep
going so my question for you you talk
about the 72 yes 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in
the morning
uh-huh yep and I just kind of want to
know cuz I know you're trying to be you
know that Jets owner yes
by the way Woody Johnson doesn't have
[ __ ] on you that's for damn sure
I just want to know like what's your
side hustle looking like right now
because obviously if you want to get to
that like what are you what steps so
when I talk about side hustle I talk
about either really wanting something
that you don't have right now or getting
out of a bad situation I'm so in my zone
my side hustle is my hustle right I'm
working 7 a.m. to you know ten eleven I
don't have I mean I I don't think I've
been home before 10:30 in the last three
years on a weekday like you know my
work-life balances and extremes I take
seven weeks vacation I have the weekends
the Monday through Friday I don't even
see my kids that's just how my wife and
I and what we're comfortable with like
that's my reality so I don't have that I
would say my side hustle is probably
Gary Vee you know I'm spending all my
time being the CEO of vaynermedia but
because of the concept and d-roc and I
and my team have figured out it feels
like on me like out and about but it's
because I only show like the occasion
you know I only talk 30 times years I
just AM able to create so much content
so I think my side hustle is Gary Vee
cuz I enjoy this so much I enjoy jamming
with you guys I'm blown you know do you
know what it bro if I could if I
couldn't make you guys feel what I felt
like when I heard that young woman say
to me I was in a job and like
I watched your [ __ ] for a year you
pumped me up gave me the courage let's
call it what it is
to make that leap and now I'm doing
twice as good and I like do you know
what it feels like to impact people it's
gnarly like like so you know that's my
side hustle thanks man
all right yes how you doing Kyle you
spent coober respect huge mistake
so I for one I know there are kids here
thank you no it's pretty impressive
thanks mom I could listen to you for
hours I think you should write
audiobooks so I can like fall asleep to
your voice because it's pretty [ __ ]
done track down yeah
oh so actually Stan you're still scared
shitless so monumental stuff that you
want to take towards success yes I I
know how you're talking about being
unbeatable in your own head yes you know
reaching that status yes of your own
self awareness yes I just kind of like
with the basics what would be your
tactics for basically to get to that
place yeah
step number one more than anything I
alluded to it when I talk but this is
why I love qat
you have to figure out whose opinion is
dictating your actions beside yourself
you have to figure out who has say let's
keep it on him right now because it's
gonna matter for a lot of people let's
actually play through this who in your
life has say when you do [ __ ] who
factors in who runs through your mind
who do you who are you curious about on
how they would react or think who are
those people honestly that would
probably be like actually curious right
here yeah Pierce if you saw the viral
video or on-site viral picture he was
the one that was praying so Pierce's
opinion matters absolutely who else my
girlfriend and my
great you need to get into a place where
you respect Pierce girlfriend parents
you love Pierce girlfriend parents
you'll do anything for Pierce girlfriend
parents but you get into a place where
you you don't give a [ __ ] about Pierce
girlfriend and parents you have and
listen like I don't know you know it's
just it's pulling so hard from opposite
directions like you know I want to stay
on this cuz this will really be a big
unlock if I can get one person to like
shift the hair it's huge it's crazy to
me how much I care about everybody's a
phase like these two people in the
fourth row have hoodies with my quotes
on I care so much about what they think
about me you would not believe it
while equally really giving no [ __ ]
about what they think and it's like this
crazy value I never let somebody else's
opinion matter more than mine of myself
it's you know like there's just nothing
you can say from people that know me the
best my mom to my acquaintances isn't
there's nothing you're gonna be able to
say about me that makes me not realize
of course you think that you don't
really know me and that goes all the way
to my mom right like you know what
you've seen I know why you think that if
this is the only piece of content you've
ever consumed for me this is where I'm
most a little bit like I'm a different
version than I'd like I get it I get it
I'm empathetic to why but the way to get
there man is very simply you first like
do it's so weird to say do everything
you think you should do but that's what
I do
and I think maybe for me it's easy
because somewhere along the line I
figured out that I could get everything
that I wanted for myself by myself so I
don't need anybody which is a really
important thing to be in that place
where you know you don't need anybody
emotionally or financially it's just a
very lonely and very not lonely place
and so it's hard you know like honestly
I wish I could give it like [ __ ] man I
think I'm trying so hard to put out so
much content cuz it's the closest way
I'll ever get to giving it I wish I
could give it because it's [ __ ]
so peaceful you know much appreciated
man you got it
I could keep going right I'm in great
shape right like we're right cool
you [ __ ] it let's keep going Gary I
really want to go long you guys want to
keep doing this yeah yeah thanks for
being here so much lunch it fires in
this room we need it always helps like
double [ __ ] what are we double firing
yeah yes are you at the hologram super
dope so thank you fire thank you
on the subject of self-awareness yes I
wanted your opinion on someone else's
content they said that a string isn't
something you're good at and a weakness
isn't something you're bad at a strength
is something that strengthens you
yeah activity this strengthens you and a
weakness is an activity that weakens you
yeah just been stuck on that I wanted
your opinion one more time of strength
isn't something you're good at right it
can be really good at something and it
can bore the [ __ ] out of you I
understand passion yep whatsoever
understood don't you good at it
yep out of strength a strength is
something that strengthens you a
weakness is something that weakens you
yeah cool and how much of that comes
into self awareness and well I think I
think there's a lot there it makes sense
to me when you like now that I've
grabbed spit look I'll be honest with
you I'm for somebody that talks so much
and puts out [ __ ] for quotes on
Instagram every day and [ __ ] does all
this stuff it's insane how much I hate
words like like I was just thinking you
saying that to me I'm like man if
somebody's saying one of my quotes to
their buddy I hate that like I don't
want that like like to me that makes
sense but my whole big thing is and now
what okay cool
a strength is a [ __ ] strength of it
right like matter like every [ __ ]
thing I just said to me it's about the
engine to me why I like that you brought
it up is it hit you in a way that made
you thoughtful now my question becomes
are you gonna do anything with it
write to me what I think has worked for
me is the reason a lot of people people
don't like me at first is I'm Seth
cating excuses people want to think it's
other people's faults it's fun to think
you're suppressed it's fun when you're
not a manager because then the manager
sucks [ __ ] right and then when you
become a manager it's the regional
manager that's an [ __ ] and then when
you're the regional managers and a
selected
[Applause]
but who does he get to blame and answers
nobody at least for this organization or
like many CEOs that I've met my mom did
this or might here's the thing to me I
just hope it inspires you to do it if it
broke an insight to you to make you do
something differently that then tastes
better that's all I want the reason that
I try to suffocate excuses is because
it's the thing that holds everybody down
right it's the thing that you can rely
on when you don't want to work 15 hours
a day it's the thing that you can rely
on when it's hard or it's painful or you
can't figure it it out or did it and so
yet sounds awesome and what is most
interesting to me is it meant something
to you now I'd rather you not care about
my opinion on it that person I want you
to like write internalize it and go do
something with it so I just wanna know
what are some of the methods that you
use to grow somebody whether that's
somebody that you see potentially or
somebody that's listening slacking
listening it's listening everybody
there's no blueprint
there's 3,700 different things you could
be like maybe you're slacking because
you're in pain because your parents are
going through a tough time like there's
just 8 million things I always tell my
employees even once I get you to a
perfect place I'm prepared for your
family to die the next day and I say a
very extreme thing and I know it's a
weird thing to say but I say it because
I need them to understand that what I
think my responsibility as the CEO is is
to be prepared for everything like like
even like get you into a great place the
next day you may lose a loved one or
something else happens or something
silly like you're upset because you're
or Bernie Madoff happens in your family
lot like I had a friend who's like was
thought he was fine because he was gonna
hair it all the money in the family lost
all them
and the payments like life right life
like you're cruising in Puerto Rico and
you have a mansion in the box weather
like [ __ ] stuff right so like to me it's
always listening every day forever so
it's not a it's not an x-ray of today
it's not hey Susan Oh Susan you're a
little overconfident cuz you were a good
student but that doesn't actually
translate to life
so let me deploy a little humility so
you understand what the real world looks
about oh now you're in a better place
you understand but then took like a
leader is always on it's oxygen it's
forever so that's how I think about it I
got one boy go ahead take a selfie with
you sure dude who's next
go ahead I can I can double tasks do
what's up with your [ __ ] screen by
go-cart you gonna get the new one
hi huh
first I'd like to say I acknowledge the
Russian Jewish heritage I am to say a
leaked happier Hashanah thank you thank
you
also I was just wondering how long did
it take you to find the balance between
your work and your life like you say you
work 18 hours a day do you work while
you sleep as well and you know I sleep
really easy good um I'm exhausted
um I've never thought of them separate
hold on to the mic hold on
I've you know it's funny when you ask
that I've never thought of them separate
I really have it and that's cool cuz we
work a lot like my big you know it's
funny a lot of people like are confused
by my message it's why I bring up my
buddy in in California making 50k on 17
softball I want that I don't want the
Jets or I'm gonna buy the Seahawks
you're gonna buy the Jets or I want
people to just figure themselves out I
figured myself out by the way being a
workaholic is frowned upon like by the
way somebody wrote an op-ed piece in The
New York Times that [ __ ] on me you know
like because I work too much like like
there's always two sides to these
equations there's a lot of people who
judge my parenting style they think just
cuz they come home at 6 o'clock and
don't really pay attention to their kids
but they're physically in the building
that they're better dads than I am I
respect I respect their point of view
I'm understand how they can go there it
makes them feel better about themselves
I just understand but it you know to me
I want you to make work and life the
same whether that's 9:00 to 5:00
well that's 9:00 to 3:00 as a teacher
and having the whole summer off whether
that's 18 hours a day because it's just
too big of a percentage of our time on
earth it's like literally what we spend
the most time on it's crazy so to me the
only people I know make $120,000 a year
who's who if they made eighty nine
thousand would be fifty thousand
times happier and the only variable
difference is instead of driving a BMW
they'd have to drive a Toyota like it's
it's crazy how people get caught up in
the wrong [ __ ] so to answer the question
I have no idea I never thought of it
differently I grew up in a family
business so it's super intertwined right
I knew that I was a [ __ ] terrible
student so education wasn't gonna be my
path I knew that I wanted to pay my
parents back for being the best parents
ever and getting me out of communist
Russia
I felt the real passion for that so I
did think okay I'm not gonna get a great
job cuz I'm not gonna have a good
education so I'm gonna go into dad's
store I'm gonna build it up for him and
then during that time you started you
know all of us are still learning about
ourselves well there were 45 or 14 you
just keep learning right you know
somewhere along the line on my cloud I'm
a really good salesman then I'm like wow
I'm a really good businessman oh really
good manager I'm really good boss I'm a
really good marketer I'm a really you
know you just start building and then
and then when YouTube came out and I
predicted that would be big after email
after Google AdWords then I'm like I got
a knack for what people are gonna do
before and then I invested in Facebook
and Twitter and Tumblr and like you just
build and and even now I never thought
that I would inspire people I thought I
was a businessman who thought that
entrepreneurship would be like a athlete
or a rapper it's crazy like 14 me like I
went to the Jets came in like 13 rolled
due to my alley
yeah like what the [ __ ] I'm like Bieber
up in this [ __ ] you know like like so
you don't know right but I do know one
thing doing something for a living
eight hours a day when you sleep eight
hours it's a third of your life so maybe
half of your life I'm just desperate for
people to do [ __ ] they like and if they
like something that pays them less you
don't need fancy [ __ ] you'll be much
happier at the end
you know what's up Gary I'm Mike I'm out
here from Arizona
this is the best soda I'm like seriously
thinking about starting a New Jersey
location just so they can be represented
here next year well Jersey I grew up in
Ridgewood love it you got someone there
let's come so my question for you is as
managers we spend a lot of time hiring
people who are like that millennial
gesture I'm in it yes are in it yes you
talked a lot about self-awareness yeah
how do you recognize that in a 10 to 15
minute interview how do I know that the
person I'm gonna hire I don't I've got
really good hiring advice learn to fire
fast if you guys especially for what you
guys do for a living
I did it I used to pay people 950 an
hour 1250 an our stock guys at liquor
store I did it I did what you did for a
long time in my life everybody has their
ego tied up and hiring you guys have
your ego tied up and you're hiring you
think you're so good at hiring and then
you hire somebody and they're [ __ ] but
you may pretend they're not because
firing them admits that you were wrong
so it's your own ego that's holding you
back my ego is only balanced by my
humility I hired somebody for hundreds
of thousands of dollars the other day
six months ago I interviewed him three
times three times that's a lot of time
for me I fired him one day into him
working at vaynermedia one day now I
fired him four months later but in my
head he literally got fired the first
day I'm like [ __ ]
so especially for this business for all
of you guys check your ego in the door
you're not that great at [ __ ] hiring
but good news
nobody is get good at firing thank you
very that one's gonna work for you guys
that's gonna be a big one watch margin
explode how are you brother because let
me tell you why margins gonna explode if
you're not sitting and dwelling about
what you're gonna do with [ __ ] sucky
ass Rick you guys are gonna worry about
the customer and maximizing margin fire
go ahead alright so my name is Daniel
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] are you doing up there
when they question me line is right
there
sure line man respect over there happy
back in here one person
I appreciate the hustle yes smart but
yeah anyway so I get a couple actually
though it's crazy about that what's that
I actually think you're like I'm
actually weirdly intrigued by you now
I'm being dead serious that's just a
smart hack I like it work I thought
maybe they give them some more time but
they just here so it worked
good [ __ ] very awesome guys anyways okay
couple things on ask first thing how do
you not burn yourself out when you're
pushing yourself so hard all the time I
always hear people tell me like my whole
life Dan what you're gonna push yourself
that hard in this area you're gonna burn
out do you do you feel like that way no
because you love it if you if you ask me
to hang a picture on that wall I would
burn myself out before I even got
halfway to the wall but if you told me
to run like a 500 million dollar
business you know for the next 17 years
18 hours they're like bet okay
okay so now they want to ask you if
that's how like you are at that point I
guess great leaders can inspire people
yeah bring them kinda the same point
right the same goal the same mission
how can you inspire other people to feel
that same like desire and keep pushing
and not stop now feel like they need to
take a break every other day
by listening to them it's gonna be the
same [ __ ] guys it's not about us like
you're like you're a great leader
inspired I'm like yeah by never thinking
about my part I'm a great leader 9
inspire because I listen because I
deliver when people ask for things
including hey I don't like this I'm like
look you don't like this
so there's somebody that I'm about to
let go right she's on her seventh
Department she didn't wanna do this she
don't do that sure
right and I've been trying try and try
it I'm over it fit try really seven is
[ __ ] crazy you know like you know
like and so and so it's about them bro
like like by the way to build a great
organization you need B's and C's
I love C players who's gonna do C player
[ __ ] if we all had a z' nobody be doing
anything everybody would be strategizing
and architecting I love when people like
on my blog or like what do you do all
day you don't [ __ ] work your meetings
all day I'm like yep yeah like like
understand 16 year old charlie from
Calgary that doesn't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about like you'll one day
hopefully understand what it is and what
you're in is you're thinking all day
you're making decisions all day that's
why then executive does like I'm sorry I
missed the times of stocking shelves you
know like it was easy it was [ __ ] fun
you know like and so yeah man it's about
them and like they're not gonna beat you
they're not they're not as ambitious as
you and that's awesome what you should
do is figure that out and then try to
make them the best version of that
player not everybody can be the
quarterback man long snappers matter too
hey Gary what's up how are you man good
man my name is Chris first of all I I
just I mean I'm in heaven sitting here
listening to it's amazing I stumbled
across to your USC video a couple years
ago and it's been I just absorbed tons
of your content thanks brother I see and
I also think it's cool that my wife and
I were in New York about a year and a
half ago and I sent a tweet at you
asking if you wanted to go to the Knicks
game and I thought it was so cool that
you actually responded like you say you
do and thanks it and you sent a video
and I thought that was rad thank God
yeah so it's cool I appreciate it
question that I've had for you kind of
in my head and by the way real quick I
apologize like that to me is super
important especially for a lot of
managers here when a customer tweets
anything about your business to take the
13 seconds on the way to going taking a
piss to make a video and be like thank
you or I'm sorry is so powerful like I'm
busy as [ __ ] dudes in New York like you
want to come to the Knicks game that's
not the [ __ ] that you're supposed to be
answering but because I did it builds a
deeper relationship with us
he's like [ __ ] that's pretty like he's
like it just it's just real like so
actually I got something fun while we're
having this conversation I want
everybody open up Instagram and go to
Oprah Winfrey's account at Oprah and I
want you to scroll all the way down all
the way down to her first photo ever I
want you to look at it while I'm giving
this point I'm sitting with her and I
I'm putting Oprah on Instagram I'm in a
room with Oprah [ __ ] Winfrey and I'm
like Oprah Instagram it's gonna be
important to the day that right and
she's like did it I'm trying to explain
to her why it's so important to reply to
people and I go to her when you were
doing your show at the height of your
popularity when you guys would stop and
reset the cameras right I'm like did you
ever look at anybody in the audience and
she's like yeah that was like did you
ever smile or wink at anybody she's like
yeah I'm like do you know they've been
telling that story for the last 15 years
it matters man depth versus
with the way you get more customer count
in your locations is by over indexing on
the ones that are coming in in the first
place good you know it's something going
along with that that I've told a lot of
my crew about is the Rickey Henderson
effect that you talked about I think
that's huge you just that's what I call
it yeah when I work just real quick when
I was 10 I went to a Yankees game was my
first game we were poor like going to a
game was like crazy it was like I think
I wore a suit you know like and Rickey
Henderson was coming off the field and I
stood up and he winked
now what's crazy about the story is it's
like if I like 80 people just on I
winked at them right so I don't know if
he really winked at me but if like the
amount of Rickey Henderson baseball
cards and jerseys and to this Here I am
right 30 years later talking about
Rickey Henderson
death man depth versus width and by the
way that's how you got to manage Sally
who works for you for four months at the
front of the store because you really
gave a [ __ ] in 13 years when she's a top
executive does a business development
deal with you because you did the right
thing because kindness is practical and
karma is ry+ and honestly honestly this
was not a big enough reaction to that
statement you got to really get it
through you know those claps are dick
for what I just said it's a big deal
it's a big deal
that's so my actual question oh yeah you
know I've seen you scale from 400 people
a couple years ago to 800 now and we've
grown a lot my wife and I have about 250
people on our trail cheese and it's it's
been really hard on me we've grown
quickly in the last year we've went from
about a hundred to 250 and years more
locations yeah yeah so how do you how do
you connect with your your people you
have a technology yeah
do you have everybody on your text yeah
lay in bed in Taksim yeah here's a big
one here's a big one
don't judge yourselves there's 230
vaynermedia employees watching this
video right now and be like [ __ ] that
guy I haven't heard from him in seven
months
like I don't judge myself I know I'm
trying with all my [ __ ] might but if
like something slips through the cracks
or if I go through a bad rally or two
maybe my number one two three guy like
my guy who's like [ __ ] you don't talk to
me and like I don't judge myself I try
real hard but I don't [ __ ] myself by
shortcomings because I know that I'm
trying harder and better than most and
life is about alternatives when I'm most
down on [ __ ] I say to myself would they
be better off somewhere else
the answer's no it's good thank you you
got it
how are you I love it you're the best
you snuck in yeah they're great I get it
so did you literally break the [ __ ]
[Applause]
respect respect I was I would have
thought it would have been way cooler if
you just snuck the [ __ ] in thank you I'm
flattered
how are you okay but trying to break out
of that move up in the restaurant and
hopefully one day become a sushi chef
and you know hopefully not cut off any
fingers though if you did that could
bring a lot of awareness to you and
maybe be create a viral moment that
could be ROI positive just keep that in
back of your mind okay defects whatever
that would hold me back from the respect
knife like yes but I
[Music]
[Applause]
I loved it and the day before I ran the
warrior - up there in Washington but at
any rate yeah I'm uh I've written one
book and I'm becoming you know I am a
motivational author and want to be
speakers love it and thank you and yeah
I'm just wanting to move forward with
that and I'm working on my second book
right now and I've started yes and
watching you the past few months a year
I've been totally fired up thank you and
I love you man I love you back no thank
you
and are you trying to figure out how to
make that more successful yeah are you
putting out content on a daily basis yes
how what what about YouTube I just
haven't done very much at all so what
about Instagram I've downloaded
Instagram and I've begun putting content
on there just having such what's your
name Shane Shane Shane let's go let's go
a different route Shannon why you do me
a favor I want you to send me an email
to Gary at vaynermedia calm okay
you got that you know vaynermedia right
yeah okay say it's Shane I'm the guy who
you know spoke at the event and the
marathon's and you know made the joke
about the cutting the thing all that put
it all in the title okay instead of me
giving you one tidbit Shane I'm gonna
fly you to New York City to vaynermedia
and you're gonna spend a day with me and
my team and we'll show you
[ __ ] that
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's keep it going I gonna top that bro
worst spot ever
respect how are you I'm good man damn
damn that respect that you're a straight
shooter you don't sugarcoat anything
and I'm just curious what you have for
us as a company as your biggest
criticism or some advice for us as a
company that's a great question so you
know what's cool about that that's a
super great question and like [ __ ] I
really am sad with what I'm about to say
which is so if somebody at marketing
conferences a lot of times people say
hey this happens every conference hey
Gary
name one brand that's doing social media
really well that's not a vaynermedia
client and I always look like a douche
because I'm like I don't know and the
answer this is such a great question and
it was a great follow-up to that moment
I can't answer because I've not spent
one minute auditing the marketing or
organization I've understand the
founders intent very clearly we've had
some people out from the organization at
four DS or one day session so I got a
little vibe I spent some time I've
clearly got a sense of the energy I I
have made a living by treating my
company like a family which means that
you get all the things that come along
with a family I've made less money
I've got weirdness of people that have
been with me for a long time that are
probably in bigger spots than they
deserve - when I start auditing this
company from afar it's the critiques
that I would have I can't critique
because I'd be a hypocrite because I do
so many of them myself but as far as
like from a marketing standpoint what
you guys are doing on Facebook and they
like bigger marketing digital like
things that I could really help with
internally operational I love all the
strengths and all the weaknesses I
understand and they just happen over it
you fix those over time that's an oddity
I don't have a sense of the marketing so
in a world of shooting it straight the
answer is I don't know and that sucks
but that's cool man thank you
hey great hey man I'm Logan hey Logan
number two I guess
number two SN you're the second Logan
that spoke today who's Logan in here
alright she's alright let's go okay so
my first question of - no but I can tell
you one thing because it doesn't matter
you're not doing enough Instagram
influencer marketing you should bet the
[ __ ] farm on it given the nature of
the business you you can't and you guys
are westcote like that it's you have
their sin there's an alpha mom in Tempe
Arizona that you could give $50 to or
five free this or ten free that or one
month free this who's the alpha mom of
your entire 5-mile radius by her just
giving you love three times on her
Instagram it's gonna disproportionately
change your business at a local micro
level multiply that by seventy four
thousand humans and you change your
[ __ ] business
how the [ __ ] do you think I got here
like humans are amplifying my [ __ ] I do
in two ways i hack attention to
understand where people pay attention
and I do nice human things that I'm a
good dude and it makes people want to
talk about me and I'm smartest [ __ ]
charismatic as [ __ ] good
so I still have two questions God
respect Logan the third first question
is we have a social media account times
three probably for each thing for like
almost every location that we have so
every location has three different
handles no every location has a facebook
Instagram atwitter and probably a
snapshot okay I like it
if you're doing anything with it like
having one for this location and like
it's somebody's fifth job who's also on
shift and does it once in a while like
that's bad but if it's actually being
run it's good it's like what's the ROI
of having a Instagram handle for every
account it's the same question is the
ROI of a basketball for me zero for
LeBron a billion if a location uses
those four things properly they're gonna
get ROI I don't think it confuses the
market like I'm not one of these people
that thinks just the main handle should
do all the work
I think they should work hand in hand
because you could do different things
because the local context of a single
location can reference the high school
football games victory and so that's how
I see it but you got to do something
with it you can't give it to like Sally
on her fourth job you know to do in
between you gotta invest yes we didn't
see each other because everybody's
flying in and flying out so my biggest
takeaway was we're busy as [ __ ] and we
didn't see each other
[Applause]
hey man so how would you define success
and I can expound on that if you sure my
first answer to that is doing what you
want every single day of your life right
like and again this has been the theme
today right like if that is to be part
of seventeen softball teams Mazel Tov if
that is trying to buy the Jets great
like to me
I lived 11 years or so of my life waking
up every morning upset because I didn't
want to go to school like I didn't want
to do that I remember what it feels like
Sunday I mean the whole this time of
year fall
I love the Jets so much right that I was
pumped but Sunday nights were the worst
like knowing that the next day was the
start of this terrible [ __ ] week that
I [ __ ] hated like now to wake up like
there's nothing I'm [ __ ] on vacation
always like I wake up every day [ __ ]
fired up right so like being able to do
what you want when you want and it
doesn't take a lot of money to do that
people are very confused on how much
money it takes to do what you want how
you want it's that you don't know how to
spend your money in the right places so
that you're like [ __ ] I need three
hundred thousand you don't need three
hundred thousand you need to figure
yourself out and put yourself in a
position to succeed but that's the
answer
do what you want every day yes focus on
your easy my selflessness comes from my
selfishness right like if you talk to
the people around me like I'm the best
cuz I'm in the giving game at all times
I have a couple things that are like
[ __ ] might you know that I have to do
for myself but like once you're good
your connections are better people are
confused you have to go sell flip
selfish to get yourself right because
once you're right all you're doing is
giving and everybody's [ __ ] pumped
and then all you have to do is make sure
that the thing that you're selfish about
isn't something that breaks one of those
seven people right like you just got to
make sure those things that you're
selfish about are the things that your
partner can deal with whether that's
being a workaholic whether that's being
home whether that's being into golf and
you've got a golf every Saturday could
be a million little weird things you
just got to make sure that that's ok
with the other person that's where
people have disconnect
right we only have a couple flick if you
were all if we were all ripped down to
you could only do these three things we
could all get there and I would
recommend everybody to have a few lines
in the sand and then give and that
really creates the balance got it
[Applause]
so I know what I want to what I want and
will accomplish with my life I want to
impact the world people specifically
massively and I'm not talking about
ripples or waves like I wanted like
tsunamis like I want it to be a big and
I have my why like I know why that's
solid I'm still figuring out the how
that's something i've been on for a
little bit but what's the why I love
people like I get it I love people so
much I get it
I hate dogs cuz I love people so much
[Applause]
dude me and you like I'm so weird I love
people so much I think the whole like P
animal thing is like this weird like
you're like I don't know I'm weirded out
about this whole issue I hate dogs super
unpopular people are like freaking out
right now like seven people are just
like I [ __ ] love this guy until that
moment [ __ ] that dude people love
[ __ ] animals I don't know I just love
people so much that it makes me weird
against animals for some weird reason
not that I want to kick a dog but like
[ __ ] I just wish people would like
people a little bit more instead of
their [ __ ] fluffy schnauzer good
anyways yeah sorry so sign up on that
also which really fascinates me because
I love people so much and you do too I
have no idea how you say [ __ ] I don't
care that's something that SuperDuper
fascinates me well maybe and honestly
maybe that's the thing right because I
think what allows me to deal with every
single day people like your charlatans
you're full of [ __ ] you're snake oil
salesmen you suck your daddy your daddy
gave you a liquor store they don't know
my story right so I think the way I deal
with the reason I can deal with it is
the reefs I can love so much is because
I don't care so much because I Know Who
I am when people try to troll me and
like easy for you to say daddy gave you
a liquor store they don't know the truth
which is that I gave up 13 of my best
years of my life to build my dad's store
for him and I left at 36 years old with
no [ __ ] collateral value and no money
in the bank starting over but what am I
gonna do and all my times replying to
everybody like what do I do go on
[ __ ] TV and say that's my story I'm
married now let's not talk about
girlfriends I'm kidding I I don't I
don't care because I know where they're
coming from like everybody's coming from
a perspective I deploy empathy and I
know why my sister thinks that I know
why my wife thinks that I know why my
mom I only care if I'm doing something
wrong wrong is different than doing
something that somebody else doesn't
want you to do it's very different I'm
worried if I like hurt somebody or try
to do something malicious I'm only
trying to do good so it makes me very a
peace with myself and sometimes that
means that I have to be selfish for a
moment but I know what my macro effect
is and if you want to build a [ __ ]
tsunami
you better [ __ ] figure out how to get
real selfish real fast because if you
look at Gandhi or MLK or anybody else
they're the most selfish [ __ ] going
I'm serious like go break that down like
I like this dude's dying laughing like
brother I'm telling you if you go look
at them right you start realizing that
they were selfish about having a legacy
and figured out the code of if they're
giving at all times and everybody knows
about it
that's going to build a legacy I know
why I'm standing here today it's as much
and I'm getting paid unbelievably but
it's not ROI positive to me I can make
more money other ways it's because I'm
it's why I'm going overtime because I
know I have a little more time than
normal and I'm keep going because I know
the last 20 minutes there's one answer
to answers it's gonna matter and it's
gonna build legacy
you better get real [ __ ] selfish
because you're not gonna have a ripple
or a [ __ ] little you don't have
nothing if you're not because you're not
to be strong enough to deal with
everybody likes the come up everybody
wants to be big you don't know what
happens when that happens you got to be
strong you don't know what happens when
you get the [ __ ] other side of it in
order to accomplish something that's
huge of like purpose I have to have some
key components well the first thing you
have to have well the first thing you
have to have is what do you have to give
so once I figure out the how that's you
can't figure out the how like for me
once I figured out that I understood how
to build businesses and that
entrepreneurship was a gateway to the
outcome for so many people because it
was independence I spent 15 years of my
life building a business to have the
credibility to talk about building a
business right which gave people more
confidence to look and listen to me
because if you're a 20 year old life
coach on Instagram you're gonna be faced
with cynicism because you're 20 years
old like so I think the thing that you
have to figure out is what do you have
to give you know I have confidence to
give got it like I'm a pure on full
[ __ ] attack to inject you with
confidence and eliminate insecurity
which leads to having very difficult
questions about how you judge other
people's opinions in your inner circle
that's how I got there I was like wait a
minute
all of you aren't doing your thing
because your mom parented you in a weird
way cuz she was miserable and misery
loves company so she tried to make you
feel insecure because she was insecure
and that's why
not confident and I saw what you're not
doing [ __ ] and that leads to you gotta
go confront your mom and that's like
[ __ ] that's what I had to give that
confidence and self-esteem was my drug
that allowed me to open up my
opportunities which led to the awareness
because I was never scared to taste [ __ ]
and I figured out what I was good at
because I never cared what you thought
about my shortcomings because they were
my shortcomings you have to figure out
where you have to give up bro and I want
like almost like the help of things you
say they always contradict perfect
insult like earlier you're saying I mean
the whole conversation we've been
talking about today is listen to nobody
listen to everybody yes
have you been following along at home go
reconcile that [ __ ] go ahead so can I
tell you how it break you know where I
figured something out I'm gonna try to
go there I figured out I'm like why you
know like you know I'm reading every one
of these comments right so I'm like [ __ ]
it is a contradiction I'm a
contradiction the [ __ ] is this and I
realized oh cuz it's macro micro on a
micro I listen to everybody on a macro I
don't listen to anybody so that sounds
like a contradiction because we think
they're on the same plane but they're
not right
I hate selling yet I'm a big-time
salesperson it's cuz I play build brand
so it comes to me not send them emails
and be like hey you should book me for
the talk like it comes to me macro
branding so I don't have to micro sell
but go ahead yes work ethic is [ __ ]
insane
self-awareness I
I would say situational awareness yes
where what everyone a hundred percent
and then you also say that we want to
get a technology and kids hands yes I
think that limits work ethic and they're
not mature to have situational awareness
that they ruin the reputation and
opportunity for future i reconcile that
I think that's a romantic old
traditional man's point of view that
you've absorbed and I don't know why but
I couldn't disagree with you more I
think what you just said is what people
been saying for throughout history about
every advancement in technology and
they're always historically incorrect I
could be wrong you know maybe you're
right but I think that we are very much
short-sighted on thinking about
technology because what we're not
recognizing is the playing field of
situational experiential changes with
technology's impact I mean for example
we we debate things based on
anti-technology yet we put other things
on a pedestal that do the same aka
we look down at texting and writing to
each other but if somebody writes us a
letter we've now put that on a pedestal
even though it's the same exact thing
it's just the thing that's delivering it
is different so I don't know I I think
there's a lot of places where I'd
contradict but on that one I think that
you know we were told that we were like
people were told there's people in this
audiences mothers that were told that
Elvis was the devil cuz he shook his
hips where the Beatles had long hair or
you know Madonna this or a [ __ ] you
know like that's just that's just
defense man you know like four and by
the way neither one of us yeah hold on
to it I'm talking so because I want you
to get in here because I don't want to
just because I'm up here we also don't
know and there's another thing we've
been betting against humans as humans
for a long time we're still standing
like I don't bet against humans we
compete we adjust right like technology
changes us go do you know what the
biggest fear in the world in society was
in the late 18-hundreds the Kaleidoscope
everything you just said you want to
real funny [ __ ] thing take your phone
out right now and read about the dangers
of the Kaleidoscope we are scared we are
scared
I miss actually I have my time and I
think might be the early 1900s we are
scared the kids are looking at
technology too much and not looking at
the real world because the Kaleidoscope
comes out and we're freaking out and
we're looking at it and it's so crazy
that people walking around London in
Paris full time cuz it was so bad that's
how I see phones now phones are making
kids more social not less social it's
giving plenty of people courage that
they didn't have in real life and just
because it's not the way we grew up when
you talk to that I don't see any romance
of you have to go up to the bar and
asked a girl out that doesn't make you
any more of a man you can slide into the
DM I think we you know I think we I
think we put things in the past on a
pedestal cuz it's what we came up with
you know what I mean
that's what I think you're welcome you
know what up bro my name is Paul it's
called prosthetic prosthetic I started
about two years ago and Dutch president
super awesome because they have been
super supportive and they've been really
supportive my passion to raise so small
means talk a lot about creating
opportunity and making sure just not to
be fearless and just it's always gonna
be a know unless you try it 100% what I
did I actually made for t-shirts for you
yep I made a bro statics collab with
Gary B I did all the designing myself
printing and I did it from my t-shirts
and I was wondering if like it was that
these to you right now yes
who's next
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes I wanted to make sure it's pretty
presentable so I made a thermal because
it's really cold over there
yep I see mean New York exactly the
colder here you wear a v-neck so I like
yeah somewhere that's the 3/4 sleeve so
right and in the plane crew yes I'll do
that all of this is a really cool like a
suede make sure so be honest if you like
it I'll wear it I'll wear one thank you
so much
[Applause]
thanks brother appreciate it hey Gary my
name is Carlos Carlos your hair is
[ __ ] awesome you said that right cuz
you're smart that cross I'm 18 I don't
work out - I completely smack in here
let's let's clap it up for the Hustle
I've been watching you stuff for a long
time and motivated me a lot I've lived a
lot I've gone out
don't social me up for different
businesses than all that I would be I'm
just not here really just to ask you if
I could come to vaynermedia with that
other guy on the plane if you give me
take care of there's any way I can talk
to you or present an idea of music idea
we have patents foreign stuff that you
might be interested in kind of revolved
around making streaming music profitable
and okay so let's do this I love to
shoot it straight why don't you do this
why don't you email me first the
framework and then let me decide right
because so like Gary at vaynermedia
Carlos dude with great hair that's snuck
in and then just give me all the stuff
and I will reply to you within this week
okay well start the relationship that
way thank you
are they going really good man good so
I'm patty from Corvallis and as I can
speak for many of us we are college
students and our friends down in Eugene
are as well so this coupon what you guys
your bro gave me a shirt and now you're
[ __ ] leaving flight
let's boo these guys
awesome alright thanks guys have a good
flight be safe alright go okay so for a
lot of us clothes let's move them one
more time all right yeah all right go
ahead
okay College follow suit yeah yep I mean
I don't know if we have a lot going on
right good it's the best [ __ ] four
years of your life you have nothing
going on I mean you do but it's still
[ __ ] a vacation yeah most of us this
job is stepping stone to the next place
which oh by the way the more I'm getting
educated I'm gonna do a little more
homework before I get caught up in the
cult nature of it cuz I've got my own
version of that like if this is what I
think it is this is like where where
people should go for aesthetic so when
you have an organization that is
supportive of side hustle like like cool
man I mean yes and you're lucky that you
stumbled into it because a supportive
stepping stone is rare I by the way it's
just smart for companies cuz he knows
that there's sorry bro we'll get to it
there's there's millions more behind you
the reason you're supportive is it
becomes a deal flow the reason I take
care of all my employees is because it
makes ten more want to come in the door
once they know the truth being
supportive as an employer right it's
[ __ ] practical it's actually smart
instead of like trying to help you it's
unbeliev
the thematic of everything I've been
talking about positivity and offense
always wins historically always good
and you know what up know just got a
jump-scare god out don't y'all just
cutting here so also earlier we did a
exercise with the other speaker about
talking to someone else about their
weakness and what they're not good at
nice and it came up again and this is
where I'm gonna post my question there's
this inherited fear of failing in your
career your major here to create your
business moving up in Dutch Rose
management whatever and they be for
yourself
what's your one-liner for just taking
the leap and going for it
you know it's it's you know I hate
repeating myself but like I get it I'll
do it until the day I die who you free
that like what when you get fired from
Dutch gross tomorrow right right like
when you write which I can see is pretty
much gonna happen right like when that
happening right when that happens like
what are you scared of like what your
dad's gonna be like I told you you're
loser or like or like your girls like I
can never trust you I can never marry
like what it is a womb like what like
tell me the thing like what like what
this is why I'm petrified of [ __ ] 8th
place trophies if you grow up where
everybody gets an 8th place trophy you
are actually scared of losing and then
you're [ __ ] because losing is real I
love I swear on my [ __ ] kids health
I'm obsessed with losing
I [ __ ] love losing I love losing cuz
I know exactly what you're thinking
about my loss and I can't wait to stick
it in your [ __ ] face when I come back
I remember once my grandma said that I
was lazy because after seven hours of
[ __ ] dragging wood in my parents
backyard I was like I need a break
cuz she's old school Russian gangster
and I remember laying there and her
drilling me and me thinking myself I'm
gonna [ __ ] stick it to you grandma
like nobody's ever fought like I like
losing like when the Yankees and Rangers
won their championships I stopped
rooting for them people like laughing
like you're a Jets fan I love being a
Jets fan I'd hate being a Seahawks fan
cuz you won it's over the climbs over so
like that's it like like what do you
[ __ ] fearful of like your sister
making fun of you because she's got a
better job [ __ ] her that's my answer
like cool like don't forget my friends
you could be winning 28 nothing at
halftime and lose so your older sibling
that's got a great [ __ ] job could be a
crackhead next year could could because
he's had a whole facade the whole time
[ __ ] trying to suck your parents dick
right and and he's actually insecure
inside and something went wrong at the
office and he starts [ __ ] doing coke
on the side like guys don't you
understand how this is played this is
real I'm being serious
who gives a [ __ ] if you're losing when
you're in college you got any [ __ ]
years to stick it to them bro
I've actually I'd actually have a whole
different new concept
I recommend [ __ ] up on purpose I'm
being serious it's so much better to
like eliminate expectations from the gap
then you're playing with house money if
you're scared of other people's opinion
[ __ ] up on purpose then everybody thinks
you suck [ __ ] then it's all upside huh
you know everybody's like like I'm
telling you I'm not joking by the way
actually you know what's [ __ ] weird
this is what's fun about like talking
like maybe that's what happened to me
maybe what happened to me was because I
got D's and F's and every teacher and
every friend's parent thought I was
gonna be a loser because uh how many
people are 40 or older
raise your hands good so for the few of
us in here education was the only thing
there was no entrepreneurship in the 80s
that wasn't a conversation even know
what the [ __ ] word man the first time
I heard it it meant that you were kind
of like a loser like I didn't do
anything like like maybe that's what
happened to me
maybe the advice I'm giving you man is
based on what happened to me which was
because I suck so bad at school and
that's the only way that we were graded
back then that all expectations were
goose egg for me and all if it was
upside so I was liberated to play in the
[ __ ] machine and just went on
straight [ __ ] offense and [ __ ] won
so go [ __ ] up
are we done have we defeated the crowd
Oh No
hey hey Gary oh sorry I'm a coach so I
zero like never have a voice
I'm from Ben's organ and I'm the newest
assistant manager in our franchise and
someone once that podcast told me the
best thing you can do I am the person
who encourages you and you aspire to be
and just flash on to them yes go and I
definitely have those people but I'm
wondering who was yours you're so
confident so sure of yourself but when
you were just starting my mom your mom
my mom what'd she do for you everything
when I was nine years old and opened the
door for an elderly woman at a
McDonald's she reacted as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize what my mom did was
super smart she overreacted on
everything that I was doing that was a
good human trait and she held me
accountable for things that didn't
matter like grades she didn't let me
complete like she punished I got
punished four times a year every year
from the time I was in third grade
until my senior year of high school
literally I would get my report card I
would take it out of the mail and flush
it down the toilet this is true which
would buy me a week then my sister
finally broke down and would tell on me
I'd be punished for two weeks no TV no
Nintendo and then we'd reset my mom
built huge self-esteem in me and I feel
like the biggest reason I am Who I am
today to everybody is cuz I feel so
guilty and so grateful for what she did
for me that I want to do it for
everybody else which is guess what you
suck at a ton of [ __ ] good so does
everybody else
you also probably pretty [ __ ] rad at
something tries many things as possible
until you figure out what your rad at
and you like and go [ __ ] and do that for
the rest of your life and stop giving a
[ __ ] about everybody else
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks hey hi hey bow I'm here with
Dutch bros I didn't sneak in but Michel
where you're keeping it pretty shady
well I don't know like you aren't you
supposed to say like I'm from Eugene
Oregon or something like in corporate
[Applause]
respect God my question is for you with
how busy you are
yes I'm sure you have set some
boundaries so that yes spend quality
time yes family yes how do you
disconnect easily like I am aware that I
spent so much time doing me that it's
hard like actually you know what I say
easily that first day is like defragging
right like you're just like you're like
you're like still on that drug of
adrenaline and working but it's just so
important to me to win in extremities
that I do my best I would say 80% of the
weekends I or on vacate or 80% of the
vacations I'm good right I'm like
[ __ ] there I'm in it but like 20% of
time like something just happened or up
I'm hot on this wine club that I'm
building for my dad like I'm just into
it I miss wine and so like this August
when I was in my family I probably did a
too little too much wine club on the
phone when I should have disconnected
but it was similar to what I said I
don't judge myself like I'm not gonna be
perfect
I'm trying really hard some days are
bright for all of us some days are
better than others
but in reality I think I owe it to the
whole system not just my kids and my
wife and I owe it to the whole [ __ ]
thing to really work hard at checking
out and being there and and I enjoy it
like I'm always into the Jersey I'm
wearing do I love my work does it come
more natural
it does it is more natural for me to
work every day for the rest of my life
it's my zone it just is it is what it is
it's the truth but especially my kids
are now eight and five so now they're
like actually real right like one nerd
that little a my class [ __ ] that but
when they become real and they can say
[ __ ] now my daughter's like me and I'm
like Fox she's like me a girl version
[ __ ] that's gonna be crazy and like you
know like so so I enjoy it and it's
getting even better right like for me
and everybody's different as they're
getting older it's getting even more fun
and then carving out more time with my
wife I back to Jewish holidays like I
texted my wife on here I'm like so
pumped for Yom Kippur cuz you can't do
[ __ ] we're just gonna hug and lay
together like you know like just trying
the best I can
too many people letting other people
judge their parenting and relationships
this all comes down to the same [ __ ]
right people are allowing other people
to tell them how to parent which is
[ __ ] ludicrous because whatever's
politically correct now isn't going to
be I promise you the wave of oh [ __ ]
they get it right in the 60s divide and
conquer is gonna be super hot in 2020 so
I'm not relying on everybody else
telling me how to do it I'm gonna do it
the way that feels right for me my
spouse and my kids
and every day if I walk in the house
tomorrow and my little guy goes you
travel too much I hate it I will adjust
if I feel like I have to right if it
hurts then I'll adjust actions that's
that dude about the weaknesses story
words are [ __ ]
actions like I took most of August
awesome that's an action I just did took
[ __ ] up 28 days in a red Sun hurt
that's more days than I took in my
entire twenties combined off not natural
for me but it's actions and so just
hacking hacking every day awesome thank
you welcome
d-roc I mean I'm missing some [ __ ] he's
adjusting I show you on the phone with
Tyler is he freaking good alright hey
who's up oh sorry bro
so I'm kind of from first off your
energy incredible thanks for dude we do
this every day we get to vibe with you
thank you for coming here thanks man
also go talk to Logan the third yeah is
marketing and social media yeah you
mentioned investing into that mhm what
are some specifics that we could do
money we need like a specific person I
think you can hire some where are you
guys again Colorado you said I call the
Nampa Idaho I think for $27,000 a year
you can get a full-time person that
[ __ ] dominates now here's the
vulnerability who's the judge of the
person if they're good or not so if you
run your [ __ ] the key is that you know
so that you can judge too many people
outsource their social or anything their
finances they outsourced to other people
because they don't want to do it or they
don't know how and that's what gets them
in trouble you know so I think you know
I think at that price point do I think
there's plenty of 22 year olds that know
what to do I was one but I also there's
far more that don't but look the part
because they're young and they're maybe
a 47 year old that knows exactly what to
do so I think one whoever's the judge
and jury of the person who's managing
like has to be capable in understanding
what the result is and the result is not
likes and the result is not followers I
don't think you're paying your dues with
likes you know you don't take likes
right yeah so like you know this has to
be business mind you know a lot of
people didn't social media in the
beginning they play on vanity metrics
people have their self-esteem wrapped up
in how many followers or likes they get
I'd rather have four people follow me in
three of them buying them 2.3 million
and none of them buying from a business
standpoint from an ego standpoint the
second one's rad but from a business
standpoint that's those are specifics
yeah yep now that person is not gonna
work 24 hours but sure the answer is
always more you know but then and then
you go backwards so the answer is yes
now what's practical and what could you
for it right and wherever it stops
that's where you want shoot for the moon
end up for the clouds don't shoot for
the mountaintop it end ups somewhere in
the [ __ ] River where do this [ __ ]
come from thanks bro you got that 1d
rock thanks whatever gave hey man I'm
Weiland and I'm from the Corvallis TV so
I'm going through a big point of growth
in my life I'm 20 years old and I know
the next 10 years they're gonna be like
a lot of progression for me if I could
give yourself one tip when you're my age
what would it be don't count anything I
feel that do you I think I do let me
tell you what I mean literally don't
judge where you're at for the next 10
years literally close your eyes until
you're 30 same advice I gave earlier
like the biggest problem for people is
they're keeping score along the way
which means they're looking back which
is allowing people to pass them I went
into a coma in my 20s you know just like
checked out I don't think what I did was
right
I checked out so extreme than I like
stop talking anybody I just went there
right I think in hindsight there was a
healthier balance but I think everybody
else is too much the other place like at
30 I'm gonna be this and at 22 this and
if I'm not the manager at 21 than this
and if I'm not making 40 63,000 at 20
like people are just counting against
themselves because they're so used to
the game of school and rankings and
scoring and then you get into the real
world where it's detrimental not a
positive do you understand I do and
you're gonna wake up at 30 so I woke up
on my 30th birthday this is real story
drove this store look myself in the
mirror and I said the next 10 years are
gonna be really important building years
you just did that at 20 I promise you
when you're at 30 you're gonna do the
same thing so the answer is it's forever
there's no there's important years in
your 20s there's important years in your
30s there's important years in your 40s
and 50s and 60s and 70s and 80s and 90s
so don't over judge yourself do
learn the work ethic and the skills that
match your ambition thank you hi what's
your name
Hannah okay cuz screaming freaks you the
[ __ ] out okay awesome
no a hundred thousand percent
[Applause]
Hanna Hanna do you know that if you
spent the next three months emailing
people that had businesses that have
jobs that you're interested in one of
them would say yes good that would
happen free advice you got it what's up
Gary life is good man how are you pretty
good my name is Alec Kreider and I'm
here from Roseburg looking the crew know
but the one dude was doing some stuff
it's like a crazy thing guys I love it
respect first off thank you for giving
us your time and I'm pretty stoked that
I finally was able to get up here thank
you my house key this question great
I've been like trying to focus more on
stop thinking and doing more and this is
my one starting point okay we're off to
start thinking or start doing and stop
thinking yep thank you
no worries man keep it going my question
is so you do what you do every single
day you know you wake up and you run
your business and you do your daily
vlogs and you go places and you're a
motivational speaker for a lot of people
and people people look up to you and
they need motivation so they look up
your [ __ ] what drives you to do what you
do and just keep moving and don't stop
what you're doing the gratitude for that
situation
I'm completely driven by gratitude do
you know how grateful I am like do you
know what did I do
my parents had sex at this one moment
and created me like like I'm being
serious I'm just grateful like I have
such a good thing going people like it I
like it it's so good but like what did I
do like you know lucky I was that I was
an immigrant do you know how much I'm
driven by a chip on my shoulder do you
know how lucky I got that I was 4 foot
11 when I went into freshman year of
high school like all these things went
in my favor
I don't know man I'm driven by gratitude
that every morning I wake up and I'm
just grateful grateful grateful grateful
I'm 42 years old almost
and unfortunate thank you and
unfortunately my grandparents three of
my four grandparents died before I got
to know them so so not only was I born
in a communist country where capitalism
and entrepreneurship is [ __ ] on I went
to the place where it's most on a
pedestal I got the greatest mom in the
world
my dad taught me work ethic and my word
which made me not a [ __ ] artist
saved my ass right but then on top of
everything else I've had very little
death or pain around me and I'm 42 years
old
it's unfortunate why that's the case
given the circumstances before but it's
still my reality right and then I have a
communication style that for some reason
who knew don't forget I was 33 years old
before I even made a video like I didn't
even you I never thought this could be
like I didn't even [ __ ] cross my mind
I was a businessman like watching 20
year olds that are hungry and thinking
about their lives right yeah I'm excited
cuz I'm like bro you don't have any clue
where this might [ __ ] go because you
know in at 31 years old I'm like maybe
I'll make a video on this YouTube thing
like you have no idea where it's going
so I'm completely driven by gratitude
I'm so thankful I'm so grateful and it
drives the [ __ ] out of me and that helps
you like to not procrastinate and just
like being a slump if you ever are like
in a slump there sure we all are
everybody's in a slump but here's my
thing man
nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah you know what I
mean like like like like like the thing
that people don't realize about slumps
and depression things and they like you
got to break them down it's for some
people it's a real disease and it's real
stuff but that's that's that's not a
different plane but like being in a
slump like everybody's in a slump like
everybody's got adversity there's always
something to me somebody's always got it
worse there's seven point seven billion
people and unless I'm in some weird
little cage in some fourth world country
that means Amin odd in last place which
means I have nothing to complain about
you know what I mean yeah like you live
in America yeah the [ __ ] are you
complaining about you've spoken for a
lot of businesses and people and I
just wondering what do you think about
Dutch bros and what we are and what we
do and the questions that a lot of the
people have asked you yeah I mean look
the biggest takeaway for me is like
there's a lot of energy too young and
all that it's all rad to me
it's just really cool that there's a
smart operator at the time listen you
guys know me like I don't know him like
I'm not like I don't give a [ __ ] about
him like like I'm being serious I just
in the same in the same way he doesn't
to me but I it's important for me to
tell you this because we don't know each
other we met three seconds before I came
on stage it's just cool to see somebody
smart and building a framework that
works both for his organization and the
people in it I know it cuz I do it as
well and it's cool and I'm like hopeful
that this becomes humongous because you
need examples of capitalism that is
positive on both sides because I think
that's the 2.0 version right like I
think the reason I'm excited that I'm
cool to young kids is I'm teaching them
good principles not bad principles all
the other dick faces that are popular on
Instagram and YouTube are flashing
[ __ ] cars and watches and [ __ ]
Club and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] down
these 23 year old dudes mouths and it's
[ __ ] stupid cuz it's short term
behavior I think collecting popularity
because of gratitude and because once I
get them in then I'm like okay listen
you want to know what the real thing is
it's [ __ ] hard work it's being
respectful it's being a good person it's
being 30 years in the making like and to
me my energy of this is like it's cool
to see it because you don't see it often
and when you see it you appreciate it
two more and I gotta go I apologize I'll
keep it short I promise thanks for
saying much I should Gary I'm Chelsea
I'm with DB AZ we're all getting tired
so I love that you say listen to people
I get to be in a position I feel like
that's a little bit like your chief
heart officer and your offices I've been
in that great area for a while the
engagement employee retention that kind
of okay I wonder when it's important to
say I don't give a [ __ ] about your
opinion and when it's important to say
hey I need to I need to coach you and
guide you and actually pull you aside
from this path that you're on right now
I think you'd know that how long you've
been doing it six years do you like it
love it comes natural right yeah you
know the answer it's circumstantial
right like the the fact that you even
asked it that way made me new know that
I didn't have to answer it you know what
you're doing you know like you know the
thing for you and I and people that
really give a [ __ ] about a charm people
is it's tough it's so emotionally
draining right because when you see
somebody who's not self-aware you know
how tough like the games already over
right so I think the one thing I would
tell you is you can see how I talk about
these issues I go that one extra place
that most people don't go it's because
that uncomfortable place [ __ ] you mom
and this and that that uncomfortable
place is where it is because what you're
doing as somebody who loves it as good
at it and what I was doing early in my
career is you go right to the edge the
problem is that doesn't create the
unlock the unlock is when you suffocate
it so I I think about it like this I try
to give a bunch of honey before I
deliver the vinegar and I going back to
the extremes and pulling if I'm gonna
have a tough conversation I'm gonna
really set the framework which is like
look I'll do anything for you you don't
have to work here I'll get I'll get you
a better I think it's so awesome and
then I go you're a [ __ ] face and your
[ __ ] face because you're insecure and
you know Karen underneath you is better
than you so you're suppressing her
because you don't want her to take your
job
because this is about as guys you're
gonna get up and you know that so what's
happening is you're manifesting bad
behavior because you're protecting your
grounds because you got to pay your
mortgage I get it but it's not gonna
work so now what and so that's the part
it's hard but like when you really give
a [ __ ] if you're making decisions
because you have to hit a certain margin
to pay to the mothership that's
different but I know that's not the case
already
so you're [ __ ] lucky you know many
people have to make decisions on that so
you're making decisions on EQ so you're
just gonna have to go to that one I
would if you were gonna have this moment
together six months six months going one
step further in radical candor which
does not come natural to us or maybe
Dutch bros radical candor stuff I get it
and by the way not maybe Dutch bros
everything I can tell already makes me
know that they're not good at it cuz I'm
not good at it when you're so EQ doubt
and it's so good vibes you're leaving
money on the table because it feels
better so radical candor comes hard but
it's the evolution for him and me in our
next frontier for us to take our
companies to the next level we have to
inject a little bit of that and the way
I'm doing it is a different version of
what we've been doing this now me
talking to him I'm creating bigger
severance --is real packages mascot jobs
that don't bother anybody else anything
if I have to deal with the 17 people
that I'm emotional towards that are
[ __ ] everything else up but not
addressing it will collapse the whole
[ __ ] Empire and that's why I call my
organization the honey Empire the honey
Empire it's not the empire of honey I
will always choose people 0.1 percent
more than the business but after you get
into year three seven nine you get to a
scale where your strength becomes your
vulnerability so yeah
with radical candidates it's the
Millennials in the Generation Z that's
coming up that seemed a little more
sensitive towards that kind of yeah but
I'll be honest with you that's a cop-out
I really I don't want to I don't want
I'm not gonna let the Millennial
Generation Z be the conversation I
actually think that we should be looking
at ourselves and not them because it's
easier to be like you [ __ ] kids I
don't believe in that [ __ ]
I really don't it's us you know you know
it's us there are big boys and girls you
know and there was plenty of [ __ ]
people that were softest [ __ ] in their
40 sixties and 80s - that were lazy as
[ __ ] and entitled as [ __ ] like this is
this is in the same way with that dude
with the technology we are we are using
the Millennial and the gen Z cop-out of
entitlement could not address it because
subconsciously we've got our own things
to work through it's always our fault
[Applause]
until this day I get I never heard of
you either here we are I'm gonna
definitely look up you you're like
straight out of central casting thanks
what's your name my name uh well my name
is Kyle but everyone just calls me by my
last name roto Road oh yeah man thanks
Barry it's still red oh so I have two
questions for you
cool the first ones about snapchat okay
so I run the snapchat for my franchise
yeah it's a West Valley Arizona they all
hey they all just left except for her
they had to catch a flight she's a
gangster oh dude I know that's that's
your girl yeah I know you're dating her
like she's really your girl okay
it's not exactly where I was going but
makes it awesome
go ahead so what is it like what can I
be doing to make it better
not even to make it better cuz I look
damn yeah I guess but like do you do you
want people to come into the store
what's up we want people to come to the
business right hell yeah let me throw a
really interesting curveball at you you
should literally take the account right
now look at it and be like hey guys what
can I do here to make it better for you
like one of the craziest moves in social
that I find fascinating is just asking
the audience what they want you will be
blown away by how much feedback you'll
get that will unlock right literally
like hey it's Rhoda you know I you know
I run the [ __ ] [ __ ] for this store
like what up like I need you guys to
tell him now you got a foot snapshots
legit now you could just keep holding it
down so you're [ __ ] good you don't
have 10-second pull [ __ ] anymore right
so you're just holding it down and
you're like [ __ ] throat Oh what up
like [ __ ] run [ __ ] here like what do
you guys want on this snapchat and
here's what's gonna happen
80% of them gonna be like give us free
[ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] dicks like that you
know the exactly which you can mix in by
the way I'm on a whole kick at Wine
Library now every Saturday we're just
giving away ten dollars worth of gourmet
food I'm like doing it like the ROI
actually works so like giving away free
[ __ ] people like the [ __ ] on it it's
kind of clever if you've got something
good because the cost of entry is low
but look you know this people want
entertainment yes and you're [ __ ]
entertaining just on your [ __ ] face
you know I need it yeah so hard I
believe you so just be a me remember
when I talk about bet on your strengths
and out of your weaknesses go [ __ ]
all Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
you know like like don't all I mean it
poke you I I could taste it from this
far away you'd be entertaining as [ __ ]
and it will bring people make every
[ __ ] person wanna watch it for you
and [ __ ] Larry the [ __ ] mop guy
cuz he's funny like create a [ __ ]
sitcom bro thank you hey so before I go
to my second question yeah would you
mind
took that snapchat right now yeah let's
do it I appreciate done yeah righto dude
I'm faking all right here we go brother
go ahead bro what's up DB West Valley
I'm here with ghetto I'm here with Gary
B he's a huge motivation motivational
speak he never heard of me before today
but we're here and we are curious to see
what you guys want to see I were curious
to hear what you guys want to see on
this snapchat so tell him tell him what
you [ __ ] want can we do that that's
okay right it's good it's approve
improved from the top
[Applause]
but from that I bet you are rode out
alright okay number two everything
you've been saying about like self
insight and self-awareness man yeah I'm
just good it's delicious right yes
what the DSLAM pack cinnamon a little
bit good so have so me ahead we're not
going to it what you've been saying with
like how you are constantly finding out
new [ __ ] about yourself everyday but
like also you kind of have this core
principles well yeah of like you know
what you're telling that guy [ __ ] your
girlfriend yeah like about them you love
them but who gives it don't [ __ ]
listen to them um how do you like while
you're still constantly learning new
stuff about yourself every day how do
you keep this self insight like in check
how do I know like you're right yeah
everybody wants to know if they're right
yeah well I mean you you don't know so
sometimes but not dude if sup know you
you you to me this is why intent has
been brought up so much my big thing is
I don't know if I'm right I just know
I'm doing things for the right reasons
and I'm okay with letting the chips fall
where they may let me tell you something
that didn't get brought up today while
we're on this kick one of the biggest
reasons a lot of you don't do the right
thing is because you expect somebody to
do that in return after you do it and
that expectation of the reason I'm good
is because I give with zero expectation
return and when you give with zero
expectation in return
it unlocks you and I can see some of you
get this like it's a big one like you
know I'm sitting here and I'm jamming
with you guys I'm like ah right appeal
you know you're trying to break down the
like I'm always trying to break down the
formula cuz it's never one thing right
it's like you know I like wine like a
good wine has a blend and components the
a lot what works for me
is I do it for the right reasons I'm
all-in I don't mind if I lose I actually
weirdly prefer it and if I do great for
you and then I need you in a year and
you don't deliver I'm cool with that too
I'm empathetic
maybe you're maybe you didn't get it
maybe you're not a good person maybe
you've got some [ __ ] on your mind right
now that didn't allow you to come
through I think the expectation of
others and the opinions of others are
disproportionally guiding your life and
I think that you will end up regretting
that in your older years thank you I
[Music]
never have to rush to the air you know
I'm like weird hey anybody are we done
yes let's do it yes what's your name
I'm shell shell
so our company's founded wants culture
and we hold it very close to our hearts
yes and earlier you're talking about our
leadership and you're saying that
selflessness selflessness and empathy is
everything when it comes to leadership
yes and I just wanted to know how has
selflessness and empathy impacted your
life and impacted your company within
your leadership it's allowed me to when
God it's such that such a good question
she'll like like it's you know it's
almost like asking me like how is brown
eyes impacted my life right like it's
it's the oh I don't even know of
anything else what I think it's done is
created a stickiness and an emotion
towards me and the organization that has
created its strengths I believe that
continuity leads to speed speed leads to
results so the reason I love culture so
much is it means that we stick around
with each other longer so we know each
other's strengths and weaknesses we've
become a gelled unit and then we can be
faster in whatever we do decisions
strategies executions when we're I'm a
retailer when it's busy on a Saturday
like everything everything so for me man
I think it's impacted like I don't think
there's an accident that this company
and my company have hyper grown very
quickly in comparison to other people's
companies right I think that when people
I feel like there's only one way to make
anybody besides the person that owns
something give a [ __ ] which is to give a
[ __ ] about that more than they give a
[ __ ] about you and in that creates the
stickiness that creates continuity which
creates speed and my genuine belief
above everything else in business is
that speed is the variable to success
thank you welcome Dutch crush okay guys
so you sat down and watch that entire
marathon which is insane so the real
simple question of the day is
what was your favorite part of this this
keynote what what made you feel the most
part do you feel the most
[Music]
do